right it's time for drew's news your
daily ratatat tat on the good news drum
and with me at the desk my favorite
co-pilot rossi ross master well hi
everybody hi jewel
before i tell the first headline i'm
just gonna say rossi looking good oh
thank you so much i'm just the moon
reflecting the sun
all right well let's rotate okay first
up we've got news about two of staten
island's finest the new york times
reports
snl's pete davidson and colin jones just
pitched in to buy an old ferry boat they
were part of a group of investors who
spent 280 000 on the decommissioned
ferry with the dream of turning it into
an entertainment venue the boat is named
john f kennedy and it first hit the
river in 1965.
it's a real floating piece of new york
history
ross
are you on board oh drew now oh i am so
proud of you that was a great pun
that was great you know i i actually
love this because you think about this
they grew up there probably riding that
ferry into the city with big dreams
their whole childhood and now they they
went and bought it and they're turning
it into a business it's going to be like
a comedy club you heard of the the love
boat this is the laugh boat you know and
they're they're investing their their
real money i just hope they can keep
this business afloat
i just it's too fun all right next up
hey you cool cats and kittens you all
remembered tiger king were you guys
obsessed with tiger king
if you don't know uh sorry but it's the
doc series we could not stop watching at
the beginning of the pandemic and if you
have not gotten enough of joe exotic and
carol baskins well you're in luck
because entertainment weekly reports the
new scripted show joe versus carol is
out march 3rd comedy geniuses great
actors john cameron mitchell and kate
mckinnon
are starring in what is sure to be a
very wild ride look at kate mckinnon as
carol baskin
can you even
uh and guess what we have a clip take a
look at this i'm so excited right we can
just sit down and talk we can come to an
understanding
[Music]
so it's war
it's war
okay
okay okay
i have to be honest with you at when i
first heard about this that they were
making like a mini series about it i'm
like but i already saw the real show why
do i mean not to be catty
but i would be lying if i didn't say
this looks so good right
i am so here for this and comedians
you know love a chance to spread their
dramatic wings i think this can have a
lot of different shades and tones in
these performances so i think this is
going to be really great yeah and i then
it caught my mind going you know like if
they're turning tiger king into a mini
series what other reality shows can they
do this to and i just want to say if
you're casting 90 day fiance the
miniseries i would like to audition for
big ed right now please please that is
my oscar
right there
i don't know exactly what you're talking
about but i can only imagine well one
day i'm going to get you on board with
90 day and you're going to love it
you're going to thank me for it i don't
know i don't think so what do i love
that you won't watch i wonder because
then we can trade and force each other
to watch yeah okay favorite shows that
neither of us are really that into and i
don't know if i'm into it or not i've
never watched it so why don't we do the
challenge you watch some you watch some
90 day fiance and i'll watch something
terrible that you love
all right we're going to do that
experiment for sure all right moving on
to an another amazing cat mom all you
cats and kittens get ready again for
this one because it is gonna blow your
mind
this is crazy all right are you ready
yes okay the week reports a woman in
england found her missing cat by hearing
it meow over the phone
rachel lawrence's cat barnaby had been
lost for eight months when she was on
the phone with her vet about her other
cat and she heard a meow in the
background and she was like that's my
cat wow and they told her it was a stray
that was brought in and then rachel
described barnaby's black fur and one
distinct white foot patch and then bingo
barnaby was familiar wow
do you i can tell you're like you're
like a little hesitant to believe this
but i mean i think you know me so well
i'm like this just is
that this is so wild i i'm having a hard
time believing it oh my god i totally
believe it you do yeah that she heard
and she was like i thought i heard my
puddi cat i believe her
because because i you know i three
chihuahuas and if one of them went
missing i promise you i would be out
there looking and if i heard one of them
bark i would i would start lactating or
something i don't know but i would know
that that was my dog i swear
maybe we could call her up in the vet
and like i'm not saying put him on a
polygraph test or anything but just ask
them like oh no let's put him on a
polygraph test her and like the little
cat with a thing
by the way drew crime true crime let's
see if they'll do a true crime with us
please
i i i i want to become a believer i'm a
slight pessimist with this one so let's
dig deeper rosters all right well next
up we got a new beauty trick i want you
to weigh in on barrymore refinery29
reports the latest trend in blush is to
ditch all those tools you know and apply
a liquid or cream blush with just this
tool the palm of your hand see she's
doing it right there so drew are you
going to try this for us
okie dokie
just
okay so you do it on the palms okay and
a little
of this and a little of that
okay
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay and hold your palms up too you're
looking a little nutso i have to say
well roz have you met me good fair point
oh this is not
this
i'm not sure i'm for this trick yum
clean up on aisle drew oh god we'll be
right back
[Music]